one miscalculation the world faces
nuclear annihilation the head of the un
wars were at the most dangerous time
since the cold war
nuclear-armed nations are calling for
disarmament but do they have the will to
eliminate nuclear weapons this is inside
story
hello welcome to the program i'm kim
vanell the treaty on the
non-proliferation of nuclear weapons has
been credited with keeping the world
safe nearly every country has signed the
agreement known as the npt
which aims to prevent the spread of
nuclear weapons and promote the peaceful
use of atomic technology
but the u.n secretary general warns the
world is just one dangerous
miscalculation away from nuclear
conflict antonio guterres says the
threat is at its highest level since the
end of the cold war
russia's invasion of ukraine has
dramatically raised the stakes there are
concerns about china's rapid uptake of
nuclear weapons the un is hosting a
conference to review ways to strengthen
the treaty but some nations believe to
hold nuclear weapons including israel
india and pakistan are not attending
we'll bring in our guests in a moment
but first this report from kristen
salumi at un headquarters in new york
the u.n secretary general kicked off the
10th review conference of the npt by
sounding the alarm
today humanity is just one
misunderstanding when miscalculation
away from nuclear annihilation
we have been extraordinarily lucky so
far but luck is not a strategy his
pessimism stands in sharp contrast to
when russia and the united states signed
on to the treaty in 1970. this is indeed
an historic occasion it was the height
of the cold war and the goal was to
prevent a nuclear conflict nations of
the world
moved from a period of confrontation to
a period of negotiation and a period of
lasting peace
as recently as january the five
permanent members of the u.n security
council who also happen to be the
officially recognized nuclear weapon
states the united states the united
kingdom
russia china and france all pledged not
to further disseminate nuclear weapons
but
a month later russia invaded ukraine
while russia claims full compliance with
the npt others consider that a threat
and it's engaged in reckless dangerous
nuclear saber rattling
with its president warning that those
supporting ukraine's self-defense
quote risk
consequences such as you have never seen
in your entire history
and then there's the iran nuclear deal
agreed in 2015. it was heralded as a
step toward reducing proliferation until
the u.s withdrew now iran says it has
enough uranium to build a nuclear weapon
[Music]
while few nations have gone as far as
north korea and trying to build them
anti-nuclear campaigners say other
countries are expressing a new
willingness to host them as a deterrent
that's what frightens valeria hess a
nuclear expert from ukraine attending
the conference
so
there is
a widespread belief
that nuclear weapons have prevented a
big war
and it turned out not to be true
signatories to the npt are meant to
gather every five years in an attempt to
advance the goal of disarmament this
year thanks to global tensions experts
say there's little hope of action
kristin salumi al-jazeera the united
nations
well the head of iran's atomic agency
says his country has the ability to make
a nuclear bomb but doesn't plan to an
adviser to iran's supreme leader made
similar comments to al jazeera last
month
it's no secret that we have become a
nuclear threshold state and this is a
reality it's also no secret that we have
the technical capabilities required to
manufacture a nuclear bomb but we don't
want that
global watchdogs say despite a small
decrease in the number of warheads last
year the total nuclear arsenal is
expected to grow in the next decade
just nine countries hold the world's
estimated stockpile of twelve thousand
seven hundred nuclear warheads
more than ninety percent of them belong
to russia in the us
the two nations have been jointly
retiring their arsenal getting rid of a
total of three thousand six hundred and
sixty warheads but many still remain
the us has been scaling back its
non-strategic nuclear weapons which are
shorter in range and have less explosive
force while russia has largely kept its
stockpile
let's bring our guests in vienna robert
kelly a distinguished fellow at the
stockholm international peace research
institute he's also a former director at
the iaea the international atomic energy
agency in lahore rabia director at the
center for security and policy research
at the university of lahore and author
of the book the blind eye u.s
nonproliferation policy towards pakistan
from ford to clinton
and in washington richard cupit a senior
fellow and director uh at partnerships
and proliferation prevention at the
stimson center he's previously worked
for the state department on counter
proliferation a very warm welcome to you
all uh i'd like to start with you robert
kelly antonio guterres says he's worried
that crises with nuclear undertones
could escalate how serious is the threat
right now that nuclear weapons could
actually be used
i don't see it very large between the uh
designated nuclear weapon states the
permanent five uh i would be very
concerned about south asia and india and
pakistan may be losing some of their
reserve to not use nuclear weapons the
concerns in ukraine right now are
probably real
but i don't see them as as rising to a
very high level right now okay richard
cupit um this u.s secretary of state
gave a big speech about how uh invested
the us us's in lowering the threat of
nuclear war but do the main nuclear
powers that we've talked about um do
they actually want nuclear weapons
eliminated or do they just want to stop
others from having them
well thank you for the invitation i i
certainly believe there's an interest at
least in the part of the biden
administration uh which you can see in
president biden's statements uh for the
npt at reducing the u.s
nuclear arsenal
but i think the question has always been
how to do that without actually
increasing the risk of nuclear conflicts
in the process
i'm not so sure
about some of the other
nuclear powers at this point in
particularly given the russian
federations as you've noticed uh noted
in your report
as references to uh nuclear weapons and
its uh current recent unprovoked threats
um and there may be other countries that
also have uh a limited interest in
nuclear disarmament at this time
um for me uh i
am with though uh under secretary uh
well excuse me u.n secretary general
guterres is we're a miscalculation away
uh i would point and uh side with
professor scott sagan of believing that
the more states with nuclear weapons uh
the greater the risk of accident theft
sabotage or miscalculation so i think
there is a uh is not necessarily a
hypocritical position to be in to want
to try to reduce your weapons
stockpiles uh while uh preserving and
making sure that you you increase
actually increase the the risk of use of
nuclear weapons in the
process so thanks okay
and lahore you see the the
non-proliferation uh treaty as as a sort
of gatekeeper with these with these main
players can you just walk us through
that
thank you so much for having me on the
show um i've always maintained this
position that international
non-proliferation regime you know can be
best categorized as organized hypocrisy
and we all believe that organized
hypocrisy is an inherent part of the
conflicts international system where a
state's behavior is inconsistent with
the norms and principles it rhetorically
endorses and the international system we
all understand is unpredictable and
complex and the rules and norms of the
system they constantly clash with the
state's national interest making it
difficult to remain consistent in its
behavior so one would argue that if
these inconsistencies in behavior exist
then new norms should be established but
we have seen that over the past several
decades
no new norms have been established to
deal with these inconsistencies
and i believe that you know
this organized hypocrisy has been a
development of popular narratives and
there has been selective norms of
non-proliferation that have been
projected in order to serve purposes and
and we are there plenty of examples you
know that uh lead us to believe that it
is in the interest of countries like u.s
and others allies other allies of the us
to pick and choose countries that
benefit from the selective proliferation
can you give us some examples for in the
interest of us
yeah so for example you know when in
2013 the us was negotiating with iran in
order to stop its nuclear weapons
program or not having the ambitions to
develop nuclear weapons it was signing a
nuclear corporation agreement with
vietnam and it decided that it is going
to provide you know heavy fuel uh
for uh you know vietnamese reactors and
the vietnam at that point in time also
had a very additional human rights
record there was no regime for nuclear
security in place yet this selective
case of proliferation was happening
while on the other hand iran was denied
the same
i want to throw it over to robert kelly
um to get your take on that is this
organized hypocrisy by some of those
main powers i'm thinking about orcas
that the deal between the us australia
and the uk to let australia get
nuclear-powered submarines which
china is obviously very concerned about
um you know is there some hypocrisy
going on
there's major hypocrisy there and i
think giving this over to lawyers and
accountants has shown they're easy to
get the wrong end of the stick uh the
problem right now is that australia has
six small diesel submarines that they
use for coastal defense
and some where the the french offered
them replacements for those same
machines
what has happened is the us and uk
waited in
state stabbed the french in the back
and convinced the australians that they
need eight nuclear submarines that are
capable of launching uh
[Music]
missiles at the chinese mainland from
the south china sea that's the big
problem they're not nuclear missiles
they want to launch but land attack
missiles
australia has turned its entire program
upside down
from coastal defense to attacking china
and if you don't think that's going to
cause problems just watch what's
happening with china they they see it as
a major threat
and to the earlier company i would like
to say that russia has made some very
threatening comments donald trump made
the same comments about his red button a
couple of years ago and the hell that he
would rain down on north korea so a lot
of people can make big talk but let's
see if they really need it just before
we move on um mr kelly from you you
talked there about you know russia uh i
guess it's been accused of of nuclear
saber rattling but then uh at the
beginning of this um
of this conference these talks happening
uh president putin wrote we proceed from
the fact that there can be no winners in
a nuclear war and it should be it should
never be unleashed so is that really
nuclear saber rattling or is russia
opening up the door for discussions
i think what we're missing here is there
are several different um
scenarios we should be looking at
there's the bilateral problem between
but mostly the americans and the
russians who've dealt with it for
decades with arms control and then there
are larger issues of the perm five and
there are larger issues yet of the perm
five plus the states that have nuclear
weapons but are not part of the um npt
where you put north korea in that and is
difficult to say so i think what we're
thinking here is the bilateral issue
between russia
and the united states yeah there there
is danger there but that and it's
complicated by nato of course because
the other nato members are nuclear
umbrella states but that i think is
where we might be concentrating right
now
richard cupit uh in washington dc how
has the war in ukraine changed the
calculation around warfare and around
nuclear weapons and around nuclear
deterrence
well i i think that's the impact is is
still to be determined but uh the
immediate
situation is uh i think it's hard in
some positions in terms of uh those who
are supporting the ban treaty for
example um but at the same time it has
moved some other states that uh had not
been uh in in prior in prior years
supportive of let's say an extended
nuclear umbrella
mainly sweden and finland uh towards
nato
which i think russia did not really
anticipate or or hope would happen as a
result of the uh second invasion of
ukraine so i i certainly
uh think it does have some uh additional
impacts we
personally uh having uh worked at the
united nations as well as state
department i would have
i think it's going to be very difficult
for the us diplomats to trust uh their
counterparts on the other side given
what's been said
um and
in addition i think uh
i think another
thing that's another development is
though there may be some more serious
discussion of the safety and security of
nuclear power plants uh which
given the what's happened in ukraine but
and this seven pillars uh
idea that's been endorsed by the board
of governors uh that came from uh
director general grossi i think those
that that's a that's a discussion that
needs to be
moved to the forefront because uh we're
especially as we see
uh an increase in interest in nuclear
power around the world
in order to address some of the issues
related to climate change
um i want to come back to you uh rabbi
akhtar to talk a little bit more about
this idea of hypocrisy because when we
talk about the main nuclear powers the
u.s uk russia china france what about
the other suspected nuclear powers
israel india pakistan
why is it uh okay for them i guess u.s
allies to to have these weapons but not
their adversaries say iran
i think that's a great question and it's
also uh you know to deal with the
gatekeeping and the kind of power they
have by dividing the world into halves
and have nots and even you know with
israel india and pakistan that are
outside the entity and have nuclear
weapons are considered to be
illegitimate nuclear weapon states they
are called nuclear armed states and
nuclear possesses states but not nuclear
weapon states uh so even with the
lexicon you know you try to control uh
power and to what it means to these
countries um i believe that you know
countries like israel for example there
is hardly any conference that i have
attended on nuclear weapons in which uh
you know israel is invisible nobody
talks about israel's nuclear weapons
nobody talks about uh you know what is
stopping middle east from achieving a
nuclear weapon free zone well all the
other countries are on board except for
israel and the united states is backing
it uh and also with this uh idea that
you know one country possessing nuclear
weapon uh has a different sense of
rationality uh as compared to the p5 who
have nuclear weapons as if you know they
will be more rational with their use of
nuclear weapons and these illegitimate
countries outside the club will be
irrational where do you think that stems
from
where do you think that stems from this
idea that you know the p5 would take
rational decisions
uh and you know other nations would not
where does that come from
so it has always been you know a part of
the broader security studies strategic
studies literature where you know united
states being the first country to
acquire it generated this narrative that
you know
we are the ones more responsible with
nuclear weapons and any other new state
you know it's not going to be
responsible so this whole idea about
nuclear responsibility somehow has been
engineered and now you know over a
period of decades it has come to this
blame game sort of the thing with
respect to nuclear weapons and
responsibility
that you know i think it needs a new
narrative it needs it needs new uh
generation to take this forward and
question as to how are you most
responsible when you are the ones who
the only country in this world
who have used nuclear weapons only
country in the world who has had more
number of accidents leading
if those accidents you know actually
detonated you know uh the world would
have seen those you know weapons
detonated uh you have had decades of
nuclear learning and these new nuclear
countries have looked at you and your
accidents in the history of it and have
learned that you know what is not to be
done and are more uh you know
responsible with your nuclear safety and
security regime yet we are the ones you
know who are pointed fingers at i i
think all of this needs to be questioned
and continuously being questioned that
one rationality you know is not superior
to the others
i just want to i want to pass it over to
robert kelly was there something you
wanted to add add to that
i think first the first reason that one
believes that um
there's some rationality in the weapons
possessing states is about 75 years of
restraint and not using them if we look
at the inter the introduction that you
gave someone said the large countries
are down about 3 000 weapons i think
they're more like 330 000 weapons have
been removed from the russian and
american stockpiles and if we look at
what countries are growing their
stockpiles today the largest growth is
in pakistan pakistan will surpass
the united kingdom and france fairly
soon in being about the fourth largest
weapon state
no matter what kind of a label you put
on them so if you're worried about who's
increasing their stockpiles and who is
behaving militaristically i'd say with
pakistan and india followed shortly by
dprk yeah i i want to talk about uh
north korea because you can't really
have a discussion about nuclear
non-proliferation without talking about
north korea how does um
the dprk keeping nuclear weapons on the
table showing them off launching uh
tests
how does that impact other nations and
their ability or inability to reduce
their stockpile because if you have that
you know clear threat on display what
does it do for the rest of the
non-proliferation disarmament movement
and also what does it mean for south
korea
i think one of the first things you have
to look at is whether the north korean
stockpile is real or not uh they have
tested the number of weapons uh most of
those tests we can follow through their
lineage and see what they were for i
don't think their thermonuclear test was
i was real in the sense of being a
weaponizable device and there's no sign
that those warheads have ever been
fitted to a missile and tested to see if
they reach a target so dprk may be
accumulating weapons but they're not
accumulating weapon systems that can
deliver a weapon to a target okay
richard cupit um
how has the fight against climate change
complicated efforts toward
denuclearization because obviously
energy is becoming more expensive people
are looking back towards nuclear options
so how is that kind of coloring the
picture
well certainly i think a number of
states uh have indicated that their real
interest in expanding their nuclear
power
programs or embarking on a nuclear power
program uh in the light of climate
change especially with small modular
reactors other new and advanced reactor
systems
so i in terms of denuclearization
that's that's an issue in terms of
getting rid of nuclear weapons or
preventing proliferation uh it's more of
it's more of an issue of over time
you know i think we've known from the
beginning that
if you learn a few things from nuclear
power
they do have some application to
potentially to developing programs
so the issue has always been
how do we
uh promote the peaceful uses uh
including nuclear power of nuclear
energy uh while
restraining the
any idea of moving towards a weapon
system and that's largely through
safeguards is what we and comprehensive
safeguards agreements which is what the
iaea and the united and the
international community has relied on in
the past
so i it does complicate things because
it creates more states that
will be in a position if they so choose
to
uh pursue a nuclear weapons program uh
they however that that's a big if moving
from
being able to do it to choosing to do it
is is a very big step i think there's a
really interesting book recently by vip
from narang
called seeking the bomb that talks about
hedging strategies a number of states
have
moved to a point where they might be
able to have a program
but they've so far chosen not to some
others have actually maybe have more of
us chosen to do so but not tested not
moved beyond that so there's there's a
range of strategies related here but i
think the most important one is for
states to be able to enjoy the peaceful
uses of nuclear nuclear energy and
nuclear technologies
but making sure that they don't choose
to pursue a nuclear weapons program okay
we're coming in that is i would note
i just think it's part of our nuclear
cooperation agreements is to push that
right
i hear what you're saying we're coming
to the end of the program we've got
about 45 seconds left so it's a very
quick question uh to you rabbi akhtar is
the promise of nuclear non-proliferation
essentially
unfair because it keeps the power in the
hands of those countries that can
exploit them
i think we have much to be grateful for
uh to the npt that it has kept the
numbers low but i do believe that this
bargain is unfair and even with this
current ref con you would see that
russia
uh and the threats that it has made is
going to dominate and it's again going
to come back to that circular argument
that you can't disarm p5 cannot disarm
because there is not broader peace and
international security if you just allow
me a couple of seconds to you know i i
raised my hand uh to make sure to make a
comment about south asia being the
nuclear flash point and both of my
panelists have you know referred to it
uh 2019 bulba balaclava crisis between
india and pakistan priceless termination
squarely rested with pakistan which did
not use in nuclear n-word in the entire
crisis and the whole literature coming
out from the west says that pakistan
will be the one to use nuclear weapon so
i think there is a change of narrative
that needs to be brought about
we appreciate non-use coming from the
west but they don't squarely have the
ownership of non-use new countries like
india pakistan you know have restrained
from using nuclear weapons and through
several crisis there's a there's much
evidence to it okay we will have to
leave it there for time thank you uh
very much to all of our guests robert
kelly ravi akhtar and richard cupid and
thank you for watching you can see the
program again anytime by visiting our
website aljazeera.com and for further
discussion go to our facebook page
that's facebook.com forward slash aj
inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter we are at aj
inside story from me kim vanel and the
whole team here in doha bye for now